why don't we do this okay
for
let's assume
uh the average person
if you were to ask them what
libertarians are
uh based on the fantastic job that media
has done they're gonna say well listen
aren't they supposed to be like the
crazies aren't they like the the whole
party by themselves okay so
i think you're you're the best guy to do
this if you don't like taking a moment
sell us
on the concept of being a libertarian
what is it to be a libertarian uh we're
the people who are right about
everything yeah um well listen the
liberty libertarians the five-second
version that's
right to me the libertarianism is i mean
the philosophy is the belief in
self-ownership the non-aggression
principle and private property rights
but we really are the believers in true
americanism uh the declaration of
independence and the bill of rights is a
great way to kind of sum up what
libertarians believe in and libertarians
are the people who have been warning
americans for decades that this country
is on a suicide mission because of our
military-industrial complex bleeding our
treasury dry destroying our currency
locking up all of our people more than
any other country in the world the
national security apparatus the national
spying apparatus these are all of the
things that we've opposed for decades
and have largely been right about all of
it that's to me what libertarianism is
all about and we can speak really to the
issues that the the real crises that the
american people are facing to me that's
more or less what i you know in a very
quick version what i try to say we're
about let me give you can you can you do
me for everybody just turn off your
phone sometimes some phones yeah verizon
especially we'll do that you're going
off no mine's off okay so if you guys
can turn off your phone for whatever
reason i caught that a little horizon
right in the middle of my awesome
elevator
verizon so if i could be clear
libertarians say you can be as liberal
or as conservative as you want to be
just don't force your views on others
localism to where the government's job
is protecting the rights of the
individual from the local bully that's
the critical aspect how it should work
if you say to yourself i am super
liberal go great do you think it's the
government's job to enforce your world
to be more liberal if you go yes you're
a democrat if you go no it's my job
through my works through my through my
example through my community to make the
world more liberal you're libertarian if
you go i'm super conservative great is
it the government's job to make the rest
of the world more conservative yes
you're republican if you go no it's not
the government's job it's my job through
my works through my community through my
example to make the world more
conservative you're libertarian that's
the issue if you're saying i want to be
me
and you can be you you're libertarian
that's it it doesn't matter what your
conservative liberal outlook is it
matters do you want to force someone
else to be like you
right in my state new york state we it's
a very diverse state in fact queens
county is the most diverse county in the
entire nation the most diverse entire
nation so i got people saying in
brooklyn who will tell me brooklyn is a
blood type they love brooklyn so much
who are very much anti-gun and i have
people in say allegheny wyoming county
who think if you want my gun yes
someone's going to die so they have that
that difference and guess what they're
both right
they're both right if you don't want to
have a gun don't have a gun if you want
to have a gun have a gun if you want to
have stricter control have to control if
you don't don't but stop forcing others
to be like you
it's okay so that's yours and then spike
what's yours how would you present the
libertarian party my five second version
is that libertarians believe people
people do best when they're most free
now
you talked about the uh the media
manipulation that libertarians are the
crazies libertarians want everything
that everyone else wants we want good
education we want good health care we
want a civil society we want people to
be safe we want people to live in a safe
society and so forth we've just
recognized that having government
control every single aspect of society
is a uniquely bad way of doing it and
that has been the problem government got
involved in health care they're ruining
health care they got involved in
education they're ruining education we
can go down the line with that we
recognize that the more local government
is the more accountable to the people
government is and the more allowing
people to make decisions voluntarily for
themselves and working together with
others the better off things are going
to be and to dave's point the warning
we've been making is that
it doesn't even matter if it's
republicans or democrats in charge when
it comes to things like the debt when it
comes to things like endless wars when
it comes to things like you know the
cost of everything spiraling out of
control it just keeps getting worse and
worse and worse and worse and it's not
because of uniquely bad politicians or
political parties it's because of a
system that was built to keep the people
that have power in power at everyone
else's expense we've also had some
pretty uniquely bad politicians yeah i
agree yeah i agree with that that's a
feature and not a bug
jessica how about yourself um i think
that it's the woke against everybody
else and there is a great pool of uh
democrats that we could could uh take
that um
just think all this all this is insane
and they're really harvestable people
especially uh bitcoiners that type of
thing they're all learning about
libertarianism because they they never
had an any kind of way to even know what
that really has meant so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]